hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play slender the
remake now this one was suggested to you
like most of the games that I play and I
looked at it and I was actually kind of
curious because this game is not made by
parsec productions at all and it's it
looks a lot lower res than the other one
I believe it's made on the game maker
which is something that I've heard of
like a bad reputation about but I'm not
exactly sure because I don't know a lot
about it I know more about Unity engine
and the Unreal Engine than this so let's
give it a try I'm willing to UM see if
it's up to the snuff to be considered an
actual I yeah it was made with the game
eager to be an actual remake of the
Slender Man games not that I know why I
needed a remake it was pretty darn good
now many of the other Slender games have
compared besides slender haunt which has
been the only one that I would consider
better than the original sender okay
let's see what we got here we're in a
room a very boring room with a nice
floor pattern oh hello
well there's page one that was easy this
might not take as long as I buy it seems
like there's not a lot of stuff here but
I'll see as I continue to go along yeah
once again the pages are very close
together it doesn't seem like there's a
lot of environment to explore compared
to anything I played before oh there's
another one got it is there another one
in their background nope okay so we've
already got three of eight pages no sign
of Slendy yet but I'm pretty sure he's
probably right around the corner or some
no nothing yet you gonna pop out on me
somewhere maybe maybe not
yeah this is five of eight already and I
just started playing like two seconds
ago here's six of eight what that let's
go ah go away get away you doing what
the hell was that
hi guys look at you Jesus boss [ __ ] man
what the hell is that what the hell is
that I got six of eight pages in two
second then slender pops up and I can't
I literally could not look away from him
I was spinning my mouse in a freaking
circle trying to get away from him what
that was that ah I guess I'm waiting for
an answer I don't really know well man
that was freaky I mean I was kind of
putting down the graphics of the game at
first but the slender mechanics are
pretty persistent I mean I I don't like
the fact one of these I don't like the
fact there's a lavatory
I'm about to piss my pants never seen
this cuz I mean I was I mean it's really
prestigious I don't like that the pages
are so close together because it makes a
game feel very small hi I'm stuck Gotha
me this a mr. chair hello beauty ha ha
ha ha ha I'm not that person
I'm not beauty ok so then here's another
page I don't like that the pages are so
inclusive and close together I'm not
sure why why they are and I didn't I'm
not in a bathroom I look like I'm in the
same place just a different location
wait hang on let me see something here
cuz this all looks the same
I mean if I were to judge by the labels
there should have been six different
levels maybe they're a slightly
different layout but
everything looks so much the same ah
here is the bathroom help me why do you
need help go into the bathroom it Oh
leave me alone
oh sorry whoa sorry I'll just I'll go
you can go about your business on your
own so anyway um what I'm saying is I
don't know why the environments are all
the same I mean I don't know like I said
I don't know much about game maker but
I'm assuming that these are all
prepackaged textures and objects in the
environment like the trees are all the
same the trees are pretty low res too
just along with everything else I mean
how old is the game maker I'm not
exactly sure what kind of high quality
processing you can make with it hi buddy
you're just standing pretending to be a
tree tall [ __ ] I mean this Lenin is
pretty good that's gotta be custom from
what it is but I'm the rest of this I'm
just not so sure about what happened
what happened don't just play the music
and never mind don't just do it during
and make me think that something's
actually happening did I already get the
page in here no this is a different
bathroom but there's no page maybe
there's no no page okay so I don't know
if this environment is bigger or smaller
I get so easily hahahaha that's what
happened
okay he's there how do I get rid of them
with Wow ah
alright then
what do I do about that I need to go in
that room I think there's a page in
there
you gone nope he's still there do I see
a page stop it he's not doing anything
calm down I game needs to calm down
mm-hmm where am I gonna go besides that
I went outside so there's gotta be you
know this is the other bathroom that I
just went in one with leave me alone on
the door this isn't gonna help me this
does not ell me wait is he gone God he's
not gone
he did not go away huh oh man I thought
he was gone
it looked like he never mind let's try
that again I mean I was I kind of feel
bad for putting it down in the beginning
Bews I gotta remember even these low res
games can be scary because I mean the
immersion of the game isn't there I
actually I want to take that back I'm
not saying it's scary it's surprising
and surprising and scary are totally
different things like with sled um in
there oh I totally miss his cage well
dammit that means I need to get through
there Slendy you gotta move one way or
another I gotta get in there here's
something else but anyway um what I'm
trying to explain is and there's a
difference between scary and surprising
I mean the way the game is set up it's
not bad it's definitely pretty good ah
it's surprising anything yeah [ __ ] I'm
so bummed
all right um man that game is hard I
mean is that the page is really close
together but once he starts being there
he's there for good I mean that does not
that does not bode well for me um let me
just try one more of these let me go to
the actual forest I'm what I'm what I'm
trying to explain is that in a game
immersion is everything and even these
low res games can give you immersion but
it's just harder to do this game isn't
exactly though make me fear for the
environment the environment is too bland
do the same to be any sort of scary and
here's some woods okay I'm beginning to
think that they just section off
different areas of the map to make the
levels seem different but this game is
not what I would call immersion emergeny
it has to be I mean immersion is thrown
around a lot especially in horror games
but in any game since we know that this
isn't actually affecting us in real life
this isn't actually threatening to us as
a person we have to feel like we're a
part and get lost in the game and you
can get lost in any type of game but if
you don't get lost in a horror game and
you feel disconnected from the person
who's playing it then that loses the
element of fear and apprehension you
have for moving forward in a war game
and that is the most important thing
that you can have it anymore again you
have to feel like you're in the person's
shoes things through his eyes and this
force is big and I'm getting lost but I
wouldn't say that I feel scared to be
here like the environment isn't like
what it was in the original Slender and
because this game says it's a remake and
because it says that it's a remake and
it claims to be a remake I have to judge
it based on it wanting to be a remake of
the original and it's actually a step
backwards from the original in terms of
quality and environment it's just too
static to sembly there's no Staubach
I thought that slenderman mechanics were
good but at the same time they're not
because um it seems very simplistic a
bit about his rules his AI is very
strict and uncontrolled and I don't
maybe I just don't understand it but it
seems very apparent what he can do and
it makes it almost impossible to get
away and the environments are SMO so
small and cramped that I don't think
it's it's a good slender game it's
season it startled me quite a few times
there but at the same time
excuse me at the same time it's just not
what I would expect from something that
would claim to be a remake of this loner
game and it's not like the best slender
game that I've ever played flounder Haun
had to be one of the best just because
the environment was so great the
environment was everything and it was so
terrifying walk around in that huge
forest and everything like that but this
one I don't think the game maker is the
appropriate thing to move forward with
any sort of good came I've heard bad
things about the game maker and I don't
have a good impression of it I've played
one more game that was made on the game
maker and it just was not up to par this
one is alright I would give it a man out
of whatever that means take that for
what you will
yes I've watched Conan I know he does it
out of this out of is this is bad and
this is good then it's all over fo I
bought I watched this Tomb Raider 1 but
that's totally the other story so take
this role you will you guys play it it
seems really hard so if you guys want to
challenge this might be it for you so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always Oh see you
Oh
not us
shop